[Musique]
aujourd'hui plus de 30 % de notre
population connaît des difficultés
d'accès numérique la population
d'Anville petit village du loirécher de
472 habitants ne déroge pas à cette
situation c'est pourquoi avec l'ensemble
des élus nous avons décidé de sonder nos
concitoyens pour mieux appréhender leurs
difficultés et leur apporter une réponse
adaptée concrètement c'est par
l'organisation de de H8 ateliers de
formation au numérique d'une durée de
20h pour un public des plus jeunes au
moins jeunes pour leur permettre de leur
faciliter l'accès à tous les services en
ligne c'est concrètement une action pour
réduire la fracture numérique pour créer
du lien une action concrète de proximité
des élus vis-à-vis de leurs concitoyens
le sens de notre engagement et de notre
implication vis-à-vis de notre
population